هذا واتهم رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطني في
تونس احمد نجيب الشابي الرئيس قيس سعيد
بتوظيف القضاء العسكري للانتقامي من خصومه
واصداره احكام كلها تتعلق بتدوينات او
تصريحات عالميه شاب يعتبر في مداخلته خلال
ندوه سياسيا المحاكمات العسكريه مضره
بسمعه البلاد وبحياد الجيش واكد الشاب بان
الحقبه التي يصفها رئيس خسيس سعيد
بالعشريه السوداء كانت عشريه الحريات
والمؤسسات والفصل بين السلطات على حد قوله
هذا توظيف للمؤسسه العسكريه في الحياه
السياسيه
وان هذا مضر بالبلاد
ومضر بحياد الجيش
وبسمعته العاليه التي تقوم اولا واساسا
على الحياه في الحياه السياسيه لقد سائنا
ونقولها بملا
كلامنا
ساءنا ان نرى دبابه للجيش الوطني التونسي
تتجه صبيحه 25 جوليا لتغلق باب البرلمان
وتمنع نواب الشعب المنتخب
التي اقسم على ان يؤدوها احسن اداء